at American colleges if you're a faculty
member and you want more pay or a
promotion you must publish articles and
journals like these since the journals
supposedly have high standards some
researchers were thrilled to get an
email from a journal that said they're
laughing because they just pulled off a
hoax and will recommend its publication
in gender placement culture
they'd sent so-called research to 20
prominent journals in women and gender
studies race studies sexuality fat and
queer studies for this Journal of Social
Work we rewrote a section of mine Kampf
as intersectional feminism and this
journal has accepted 87 of their crazy
papers got in and one that claims that
dog humping incidents can be taken as
evidence of rape culture has been
officially honored as excellent
scholarship thinking oh my god we got a
paper and and it's probably the craziest
thing we wrote James Lindsay's a
mathematician
Peter Bogosian teaches philosophy heaven
pluck Rose runs an academic magazine in
London they didn't really expect that
the journal of gender place and culture
would accept their paper in which they
claim to have closely examined genitals
of nearly 10,000 dogs to learn about
rape culture and queer performativity do
they just not read these things and
accept oh no no no they read they read
them in detail how could they believe
you examine $10,000 Jenny we have no
idea in fact in the the first draft of
that paper we were like there's no way
they're gonna believe that we did this
we think studying topics like gender
race and sexuality is worthwhile and
getting it right is extremely important
they made this video to explain why they
tested the journals a culture has
developed in which only certain
conclusions are allowed like those that
make whiteness and masculinity
problematic basically it's not correct
that there is such a thing as biological
sex animal last-straw happened there was
this paper well funded by the National
Science Foundation that studied feminist
Glaciology and said the glacier science
sexist because the majority of
glaciological knowledge that we have
today stems from knowledge created by
men about men within existing
masculinist stories the papers remedy a
feminist paintings of glaciers and
feminist art projects that I'm not
kidding hooked up a phone line to a
glacier so you could call the glacier on
the phone and listen to it so that was
the last straw for me
these aren't your fields no no what
should have made it more difficult much
more difficult to fool the journals but
paper started getting in this shouldn't
have been possible what appears beyond
dispute is that making absurd and
horrible ideas sufficiently politically
fashionable can get them validated at
the highest levels of academic reven
studies we flattered what they wanted to
hear and then they told us that it was
an important contribution to feminist
geography maybe these are just Mills
that accept every paper you know one
journal we hoaxed was Hypatia which is
one of the two leading feminist journals
it has about an 18% acceptance rate the
researchers didn't get to finish their
experiment because the dog rape paper
was so over the top a Wall Street
Journal reporter noticed she exposed the
hoax and ended the experiment before all
the journals had weighed in the seven
that accepted the fake papers did
retract them but what upsets me most is
what happened next no university said
we're not gonna use these journals no
editor publicly said we have to raise
our standards think about if you did
this to civil engineers with bridge
building they would have thanked us
right because they're driving over the
bridges with their families so they
don't want the bridges to collapse but
the grievant study journal editors
instead of admitting that they published
nonsense criticized the hoaxers
you clearly engaged in flawed and
unethical research that was our whole
point
a dozen of Peters fellow professors
wrote an anonymous letter attacking him
and the school newspaper ran it with
this cartoon depicting Peter is a clown
you're part of the clown car of hoax
writers engaging in four
Geling time-wasting anti-intellectual
activity right they just described their
own discipline do you dread walking the
class yes I've been spat on I've been
physically threatened Portland State
University instead of applauding Peter
for exposing nonsense may fire him
I called Portland State asking for an
interview but they declined
how can a college criticize the hoaxers
but Revere ridiculous journals that
publish nonsense and you live in these
tight ecosystems this stuff makes total
sense
there's a pervading rape culture men are
bad the whole ball of wax twenty years
ago a physicist submitted a nonsense
paper to the journal social text saying
gravity is just a social construct that
embarrassed the journal but social text
is still going strong and at
universities nothing really changed the
best I can tap into is that this is kind
of like religious architecture in their
mind where privilege is sin so you can
come up with these really nasty
arguments like well it's put white kids
and chains in the floor it's an
educational opportunity and if you frame
it in terms of overcoming privilege then
it's right in and anyone who dares
criticize that must be a conservative
hack holding the same ideological
position is the Trump administration's
attack on trans rights maybe you are
just conservative hacks looking to
defend white your white privilege I
don't think so I've never voted for a
Republican in my life mmm nor of I
actually none of the hoaxers is
conservative my collaborators and I are
left-wing academics who can now say with
confidence these people don't speak for
us the scholarship in these disciplines
is utterly corrupted they have placed an
agenda before the truth after this
interview the editor of one of the hoax
journals did agree to talk to me maybe
you shouldn't be doing what you're doing
because it's gibberish and they've
proved it yeah yeah they did them proof
that's the problem that video will be
available soon